civil disobedience is still
a very important
concept in any
sensible democracy any real democracy
and that's why that thing in victoria is
very important and i keep saying that if
every legislature in canada every
saturday there were 10 000 plus people
on an ongoing basis over the next all
through the summer
that i think we could have an impact
upon public policy
hey folks welcome to the dark horse
podcast i have the distinct honor and
pleasure of sitting today with brian
peckford is the former premier of
newfoundland and labrador
and the last surviving first minister
who collaborated on the 1982
constitution act for canada
welcome brian
welcome sir nice to be here
um terrific so uh you and i have not met
before but we've been traveling uh in
parallel circles as we have watched
things surrounding the rights in the
west in the u.s and canada especially
change
as the pandemic uh marched forward
so
i think it's a good idea that we discuss
what someone who is actually
present and contributing to the
constitution of a great western nation
sees taking place in the present
so
where would you like to start
well perhaps i'd like to start with the
fact that uh
a lot of your your viewers and listeners
might be interested that
it was only 40 years ago that we
actually
as a country put our rights and freedoms
in writing
country
and that's important in the sense that
the united states of america
had a bill of rights it was 15 years
after
they formed their country so 1776 and
1791
were the two big dates in this
discussion for the united states of
america
in the canadian context
that was 1867
and 1982
so we were 114 years before we actually
wrote down
our
bill of rights if you will call the
charter right same thing
and the difference is significant in the
sense that
we've then proceeded along different
pathways as it related to how an
individual defended their rights and
freedoms in their particular countries
so what happened in canada
different than the united states was
that we
formed our country in 1867 and defined
it as a federation and the roles and
responsibilities of this province's
versus the federal government and so on
and other
relevant measures
but we
the founders decided to leave the rights
of freedoms
within the same context as britain
we didn't have a revolution
we peacefully if you will decided with
england that we would become a separate
country
and so we lived under british common law
which was unwritten british common law
and conventions are customs that grew up
over the years after
uh the formation of the country and so
they they form the basis
of our rights and freedoms and so any
individual from 1867 to 1982 that went
to the courts of the of the land to
defend their rights and freedoms did so
under unwritten british common law and
customs and conventions it was decided
uh after a long period of talking about
this many many decades that we would
formulate
a written
bill of rights and put it into the
constitution
which was in 1982
that 1982
constitution act also contained another
very important provision it severed our
last ties with england
as a nation in the sense that all of our
amendments to our constitution in the
future after 82 would be done solely in
canada
and not have to have reference back to
the house of parliament for the final
vote on an amendment to our constitution
which therefore really meant that we
became 100 sovereign if you want to put
percentages on it if we were 80 or 90
sovereign before that we're now 100
after that and so
that was a significant two very
significant
measures that were taken sovereignty was
100 percent was called patriation at the
time patrioting the constitution or
bringing the constitution home for good
from england and secondly adding to it
among other things
a charter of rights and freedoms which
define
the rights and freedoms of individuals
in the country much the same
even that the phraseology may be a bit
different but the impact was around the
same freedom of expression freedom of
conscience freedom of religion okay
freedom of the press
all those are in one section of the of
the charter
freedom of assembly freedom of
association all in section two of that
new charter in section
six was free to move
across canada or leave canada so freedom
of movement or mobility rights is called
in the charter and then there's a
section 7 which says
the right to life liberty and security
of the person
and section 15 says every individual in
canada is equal before the law so those
are the four
what shall i say the pantheon of rights
and freedoms that were contained in that
charter which are germane and relevant
uh to the discussion today and my
advocacy on it and being the only first
minister left who was at that table
helping to create that charter by the
way
um
i have become very active in the last
year and a half or more since the
pandemic really and since the government
started to oppose these mandates to
indicate
that these mandates are violating these
four core
areas of the charter rights and freedoms
and that they have no business doing
that without going through the proper
process which they didn't do i also
argue that the intent in one of the
sections which said the governments can
override these rights in certain
circumstances
and i remember well the intent at that
time was that it was in war insurrection
or some very uh you know crucial thing
that was apparel to the state and i go
on to argue that the present
circumstance
of a virus which only a 99 recovery plus
99
plus recovery and a less than one
percent fatality
rate does not constitute apparel to the
state and therefore they are violating
the intent of section one and therefore
violating the constitution i go on to
say that even if you wanted to use
section one there are four tests in
there which had to be met and the
governments have not met that those
tests so in either case the government
of the governments of canada of which
there are 14 by the way now
10 provinces federal government and
three territories all of them have
issued mandates which violate the
constitution of our country and
particularly violate that charter which
i helped create
well that's marvelous you've answered my
first 37 questions about the structure
of canada its independence its
constitution and uh you've taken us a
good way into
how things look from the point of view
two years plus into the pandemic
um let me say uh you may or may not know
i'm a scientist by training i'm a
biologist and i'm very interested in
questions of
cause and effect and
one of the things that the pandemic
allows us to do
is to learn something about what the
effect of various provisions of our
various constitutions or in some cases
the lack of a constitution
uh has done to
the
what i would call authoritarian
overreach that we are seeing across
the west so
for example what you've just told us
is that canada has a constitution
that contains a bill of rights very much
like the american bill of rights but
much later emerging and
with what i think is one major
difference
which is
and i should tell you i have a couple of
hypotheses on the table about
why tyranny has
emerged differentially in in different
western states
uh and one of the hypotheses has to do
with
the american second amendment
which
complicates the question about
usurping rights so when our government
is in violation of our rights
it has to take into account that the
population uh for uh both better and
worse is very well armed um do you see
the
absence of gun rights from
are they completely absent from the
canadian constitution yes
yes they are so uh do you see the
absence of those rights any differently
now than you did in 1982
no
no not really
not really i i it
when one considers and in our particular
case and you know i can't speak to the
atmosphere and the circumstance in the
united states when the bill of rights
came in but i can't can to the canadian
one and
at the time as we get into this
uh most of these things when nations
come together
you can go back to solenstein and greece
if you want uh when he was called out of
retirement to try to keep the civil the
civil war from happening and bring the
poverty-stricken
animal slaves together uh with the
oligarchy at the time and forge a new
law which tried to bring things together
it's always a bargain
it was always a bargain and when we
decided on this patriation bring the
constitution home and the charter
because it's a federation all of the
provinces were involved with the federal
government in forging this
and each province had their own agenda
and so we started off with like 20 over
20 items on the table
narrowed it down until we we got
something that everybody sort of could
live with so there were other parts to
that constitution act which included
things like indigenous rights minority
language rights
non-renewable resources an amending
formula
right we're all part of this as well as
the patriation and the charter so they
were all negotiated as equals if you
will factors in bringing the the
constitution together
so in that context and in that light
when you consider
what i just defined as the four areas
they're pretty clearly defined
they're pretty clearly i don't know how
you say any more of a free expression or
his freedom of religion freedom of
conscience in a constitution and i think
a lot of people at least in canada and i
i suspect in the united states too and
in the west generally
sometimes confuse constitutions with
ordinary federal law or state law or
provincial law there's a big difference
right what the constitution is the glue
and the principles and the values which
are supposed to encompass
the new government of the new
territory as well as find how it's going
to operate okay
and then you leave the rest of it
because these are principles to the
courts to more define and refine right
and with custom and convention over time
so one of the things missing and it's a
more complicated and longer defining uh
discussion when you get into it into
that context right so always so i always
say to canadians now and this is my
click i don't know how many podcasts
i've done but i guess i'm well over a
hundred now
uh every day by the way i do at least
one if not two
and uh so that'll give you an idea um
how many that would be if i'm going back
a year and a half or more on this i
always try to explain to to people
that um
when you talk
it took us 114 years to even open the
constitution so these are our documents
and concepts that are not
revisited that often we must work it out
through the principles that were defined
and then work it out to the parliaments
and through the uh the judiciary which
are other parts of the government
and so it's in that context that i say
what i just said and answered the
question
and and it's one way way
reason why i like podcasts better than
going on a live program where they've
got 30 minutes right now i'm negotiating
with a radio station in vancouver to go
on on monday i think it is where they're
going to have somebody else on to the
counter what i'm saying
but the problem is you know they have a
half an hour and it'll take me in in my
not here today but it'll take me
normally when i do a public meeting
which i do a lot of
it takes me 40 minutes to do the whole
presentation for canadians to start with
1867 and come forward and to put it in
this proper context otherwise it doesn't
it's not meaningful i mean people will
not understand it well they're they're
arguing with me now you know i might get
15.
and then they got all kinds of these ads
in between and so it makes it difficult
to understand and that's why i like your
question i'm still answering it now
in the sense that uh you know you feel
so comfortable with your your what you
wrote 40 years ago 18 1982 and now it's
2022. the anniversary wide by the way is
coming up on the 17th of april so we're
getting close to the 40th anniversary
and my answer is yes because of the
reasons i just gave all of these things
are burdens okay well i i understand and
you know of course the same was true uh
in the writing of our constitution it's
uh it's all
bargains struck by people who uh
were in general extremely far-sighted uh
in a few regards not but
um but with respect to gun rights i mean
of course our constitution was written
uh in the aftermath of a revolution
exactly one with you know muzzle loaded
rifles and muskets
uh and gun rights of course looked very
different than you know machine guns
show up in world war ii and your const
and world war one in fact and uh your
constitution uh was written more than
half a century later so um
of course you would have taken a
different view than the american
founders but i i guess my question is
this
i'm looking at
canada
i'm looking at australia
new zealand
the united states and i'm watching the
same tyranny unfold differently in these
places and i know
that canada didn't have
the gun rights i know that australia had
them and reversed course and i know that
we in the united states
still i have to say we still suffer the
cost of those gun rights that i think
ought to be something all americans can
agree on is that whether these rights
are good or bad they certainly are not
cheap
um
but
what i will say is you know at the end
of
last summer here in the northern
hemisphere i was watching
things come apart in australia and new
zealand and thinking well
why is why is that happening there and
not here and the two hypotheses i
advanced was one
they're off by six months because this
is a seasonal effect it has to do
with uh winter having dragged on now for
three months and the tyranny interfacing
with the mood of the public or the mood
of the government
and the other hypothesis was uh
that
our gun rights prevent that tyranny from
breaking out here in the same way
because it might meet a different
response and
now that we you know we've effectively
tested one of these two hypotheses
because we are now at the end of our
winter and we have seen tyranny unfold
and it has done so differently in canada
than the u.s which suggests that
actually maybe both of my hypotheses
were right they're not mutually
exclusive which is
we were six months behind
with respect to tyranny and it unfolds
differently in a state where the
citizenry is armed than in one in which
it is disarmed
and so it is that question i'm trying to
address with you which is you've seen
uh i i know your perspective to an
extent
you've seen terrible things unfold
you've seen your constitution
violated again and again on multiple
different fronts
by the current leadership
and
it is in that context that i'm wondering
you know yes maybe you had to strike the
bargain you did but would canada
um would canada's constitution be
standing up better if uh the government
had more to fear from the citizenry
uh
a really good question and i i can't
answer it i don't i doubt it myself
we don't have the same um history and
culture as you as the americans have as
as so
we come at it from a different way
all together so you know gun the gun
rights were never even considered during
the 1981-82 by the way this was 17
months negotiation it didn't happen
overnight it was 17 months of talks
between the various governments the
other issue with with a canadian would i
i had to respond as a canadian is
given what's happened in seattle and
portland and continues to happen and
happens with the black lives matter's
issue and
what is that i just saw some stuff on
seattle last night there are ongoing
issues in the united states unrelated to
the mandates which call into question
whether in fact
um
you know the way the united states is
unfolding right now
is any better than unfolding in canada
and if you include both the mandates and
the disruption of many many cities and
the murder rate that's going on in the
united states one would have to as a
canadian
uh take that broader view and say well
i don't know about this uh you know
because
as we look at our media from up here and
look at what's happening in the united
states
and i defend you i'm very pro-american
and defend your country a lot
i'm one of the i'm foremost i guess
promoters of america in canada today
who's speaking up
uh but i do
see the the cracks in the
constitution of the united states which
means some relevance to
that particular provision of your
constitution yes uh
there is no question that our
constitution is um
failing
in parallel
with with canada's and your question
about uh the
the blm riots is
a good one but i must tell you uh
my wife and i i mean we live in portland
we we watch this go down in real time
and
uh
it also
gave me
pause with respect to our second
amendment but in the opposite direction
because
what we saw
was absolute uh failure of the rule of
law
in places like downtown what we did not
see so much of was the same failure in
neighborhoods people would march through
streets in neighborhoods
um and you know there was social
harassment but there was a question
about whether or not
uh
as terrible as things were especially
here in the pacific northwest yeah
seattle and and portland if it might
have been
uh
more uh it might have been worse and
been targeted at citizens in their homes
if
uh the rioters had not had the same
concern about the well-armed nature of
the population
so
we don't know these are all you know and
i must tell you uh
i um i'm a lifelong liberal
uh i have
changed my perspective on gun rights uh
having watched
uh events unfold you know yeah
that's a good point but then you can
also argue well what was the cause then
uh of it in the beginning it didn't
happen yes and there were riots and
there were a lot of disruption at least
in the center parts of the city
but i think it's a really good
discussion and as a matter of fact i
have never come out against
the americans provision
of gun rights i have never opposed it
and for example
when i defended america i've defended
that that particular provision as well
because you know why
because i understand how the
constitution got formed i understand the
history and context of the times and i
would also argue by the way as i do in
canada now if you want to change it we
have a way of changing it but it's not
on the streets and it's not by bringing
in mandates and over trying to override
the constitution with doing it the
proper way
right well and that is the other thing
that we have to say um so i would say
well i am both for and against those gun
rights i think i am now substantially
more for than against but you know i do
find the uh
the cost of
widespread gun ownership unacceptable in
in the sense that we have unstable
people and that's an awful lot of power
for to be in the hand of somebody who
can't handle it um
but you know i i do think it may be uh
an important hedge against tyranny which
is maybe a primary concern
a very a very very good point and hard
to argue against i think in the broader
the sense of things and the other thing
is i mean
nothing is perfect and we've all learned
that if we haven't if we're
if we're if we're
if we adhere to some of the uh
christian principles and you know we all
recognize that we're not we're not
perfect and that we have to work out a
day after day after day the other thing
that has to be mentioned and i also
mentioned
when i defend america
uh
in canada is
i think right now it's the longest
surviving democracy that the planet has
ever
had
number one and number two that one takes
the constitution of the united states in
its totality i don't know if man has
created anything better today
notwithstanding the guns or gun rights
and so you've got to put it into that
broader piece piece well you know i
think our constitution has done
beautifully i think it is
now
it is at a point where the values that
it seeks to protect remain the right
ones but it is inadequate to the job
right because for example let's take uh
the right to free expression
assembly etc
that is now a right that uh is more
governed by the technical nature of the
way we speak and interact than it is by
governmental interference so to have
those rights not protected on twitter
and facebook and where we actually uh do
our our exchanging of ideas
means that they are effectively not
protected yeah i couldn't agree more but
i i was going to go on to say i'm glad
you raised it that way it's it's both on
the technical technological side but in
canada it's also day to day i mean you
know
the the dominance of the you know there
are a number of things uh operative here
it was big government
right
big press
right
big pharma
right
you know big media they all they they so
they all converge it seemed like the
ground was very fertile uh because in
canada what's been happening over the
last 40 years has been a gradual erosion
of our political institutions at the
same time the parliament of canada
doesn't exercise his powers the way it
did 40 years ago a lot of power has
moved to the cabinet and to the prime
minister's office in canada which is
completely
the antithesis of what the constitution
is all about what has been done without
a shot being fired and whether the law
being amended
and this is what's happening has
happened in australia and in new zealand
as well which are sort of british
were formerly british colonies that
became independent and so what has
happened it's been very insidious
through the media through the big
government to the big pharma through the
big tech okay that's the four the
horsemen as i call them of the now
apocalypse if you will or put a better
word where we are as countries and we
must now look at how the governments the
state gov the the governments within
these other three horsemen have been
able to usurp
right and and overtake
our constitutions
well
uh
the irony here is that the same thing
has happened in the u.s it's just
happened differently and uh i wish i
could limit it to four horsemen it looks
more like an entire cavalry of horsemen
from my perspective including our our
major political parties which uh have
teamed up in the most absurd way
to you know exactly as you described to
effectively take a
carefully balanced set of powers i mean
this was how our founders spelled it out
checks and balances they've taken it and
they've transmuted
us into something that
certainly you know there are elements of
democracy but i'm not even sure i would
call us a democracy at this point
um
there is that the organization called
freedom watch or whatever or democracy
watch that scores all the countries in
the world every year i have some
problems with some of their stuff but in
broad terms they they break it down into
and then once again it's arbitrary but
they break it down into free partly free
and not free all the countries of the
world and i've been arguing over the
last while and using that as a little
analogy that the united states and
canada up to about two years ago
one could perhaps arguably say we were
almost free
under their definition but now both of
us are only partly free and on our way
to being not free
yeah as a way of trying to bring it into
a conversation and
you know i i find these descriptions are
also not really up to the challenge i
agree with you that we are only
partially free and that the mandates we
have seen
reveal that in a way that it wasn't
clear before
but it's also the case that i think
we are very differentially free in the
u.s
you're fairly free if you're not a
threat to power
and
yeah so
this does not remind me of the country
that our founders put together it
reminds me of a
uh well uh william binney was a an nsa
officer
uh who turned whistleblower
and he hit the nail on the head he
described what we have he held up his
fingers he said we're this close
to a turnkey totalitarian state and that
the key concept is that it's turnkey it
doesn't feel like a totalitarian state
until the provisions are activated and
what we saw in the pandemic was that
many
things that structures that we hadn't
noticed suddenly were brought to bear
and what's more
the
um the agreement that the world reached
in the aftermath of world war ii at
nuremberg about immoral orders
there was actually a mechanism
to get around that well one thing is
many people
were not
uh
as thoroughly aware of the agreements
that were reached at nuremberg
but it is also the case that if you
deliver a mandate
that drives people out of your police
forces and your military because they
refuse to comply what it does is it
leaves a force that's very compliant and
doesn't know that it has to reject
immoral orders
and
i guess the third thing i would say is
one of the things that i think has
um given
those of us who do know something about
history
comfort
is that
one can recognize these things unfolding
and one can get out of the way if one
cannot
turn the tide that turns out not to be
true all of the places one would think
to run are undergoing this
uh move towards tyranny at the same time
how true we we've uh many of our friends
have had left
and gone to nicaragua mexico and other
places quite a few have left and gone to
both florida
uh and
texas and some ghana idaho and uh and
south dakota uh in the united states
permanently have left permanently quite
a few canadians have left permanently
for that reason but you're so right
because so many places are doing the
same thing just to
remind you perhaps in some cases you may
not know in canada uh in 2018 the
government of canada
in
in
negotiation with all the major news
outlets
provided money to them all
600 million dollars canadian dollars
over five years to all the major news
outlets so for example in my case as a
former first minister in canada i'm
fairly well known by those people over
40 or 50 because
i you know i'm going on 80 now
but
i was the first minister for 10 years
in one of the provinces of canada and
was very vocal
while there and after and i've continued
to continue to submit letters and stuff
and speak up about public policy issues
well a year and a half or more ago all
of that major press
closed me down
i can't put a letter in the major
newspaper on vancouver island where i
live right now in british columbia they
will not carry it
even though that meets all of the
requirements that they say letters to an
editor they're right are supposed to
meet like they will not carry it our
major newspapers in in toronto to the
globe and mail in the national post they
won't carry my stuff and none of the
major broadcast meeting will call me
even though i've just done a major
speech before 10 000 people and will not
carry me so we have a very active
you know fourth estate the press which
is completely eliminated from its
discussion anything to do with anything
that's negative about the virus itself
and how the government's responded and
negative towards the vaccine they will
not carry it there's nobody died from
the vaccine as far as the mainstream
media in canada are concerned for
example you know even though we know
over 50 000 for sure
if you combine western europe and the
united states using their own government
numbers
and so here that's how bad it's become
in canada
and the lady who became sort of the
finger head for the truck convoy that
went to ottawa was fine it was arrested
for what was called they couldn't find
anything to do with violence or anything
else it's mischief and the bail hearing
for her
her
release until they
had the main hearing in other words
she's innocent until proven guilty under
all of our laws and your laws
she had to come in court in shackles
we've never seen it before as nobody can
remember when the last time
a a an accused person and he had been
some kind of dangerous murderer came in
the court in shackles and her first
court hearing was heard by a judge who
had been a liberal candidate in the
politics of canada three four years ago
in other words and the liberal liberal
party happens to be the governing party
of canada right now she was the one who
heard
the bail hearing
yes uh
i
i wish i could be more shocked
the problem is
we have seen this
in i think all of the great western
democracies we have seen you know and
and it's
i've been struggling with how to how to
even comprehend it and one thing that
keeps recurring
is that i thought
that orwell had exaggerated to make the
story clear
and what i am now watching
tells me it was no exaggeration right up
is down
and in this case the thing that is so
troubling
is that the people
who are participating
knew better five years ago the same
people understood the rights that they
are now violating as effectively
next door to sacred
and they are now violating them
willingly and there's no comprehension
that that they are in conflict with
their own values
so
what also happens because the people are
getting their most of the news for the
mainstream media people live right
around me right outside my door here i'm
in a small 28 unit complex okay
all the people who live around me and i
live in this small city of 12 000
are getting their news
just from once one or two sources
canadian broadcasting corporation
and a couple of newspapers that have
refused to carry the alternative view on
what's going on and therefore they
support what is happening in the
complete abuse of our freedoms and
rights in our country
and it extends to every level um if you
look at my wikipedia page or my wife's
wikipedia page you will find slander
right we are we are accused not even
accused it is simply asserted that we
have been
distributing medical misinformation on
the internet when in fact what we were
doing was functioning as biologists
talking about the evidence and what it
implies we were doing exactly what we
were trained to do in canada we've got
doctors who've been fired from their job
right here in the province
just because they were uh uh
uh vaccine
hesitant hesitant right right because
they looked at the
i didn't say it evidence in the canadian
constitution and there's no law canada
meanwhile the governing authority health
authority in that region of british
columbia has harassed this doctor right
has taken away his hospital privileges
in the nearby hospital and is trying to
take away his license this is in
democratic canada as we speak
well uh i don't know have you um have
you run across the concept of mal
information yet yes yes mal information
this is true information that causes
people to distrust their government
which our government has now declared a
form of terrorism
yeah right so we're now you know in a
country where effectively our right to
critique the government is written into
our founding documents yes speaking the
government is now uh is now
treated as terrorism which of course
triggers provisions that allow them to
violate every single one of your
constitutional rights with the possible
exception of the third right um
but uh
yeah it's it's uh it's remarkable and
you know it also
there is this question about
it's this is not a secret
right you and i have seen something we
are not alone there are many people who
understand what is taking place it's not
a majority but there are many people who
have seen it
and yet
it is of such a nature that it is hard
to make the case and all of the places
that you would make the case it's like
it's like the paper that you would write
on has taken up a political position and
it will only allow the expression of
certain ideas
a good way to describe it
and
oh you know let's put it to you this way
nobody warned us about that exactly it's
one thing to have people you know uh
intimidate you for
for saying things it's another thing to
have the mechanism of speech
uh you know turn off your microphone as
you try to make certain points
especially you know scientific points
right yes absolutely absolutely and
i have this i have to tell you and you
you refer to it there um there are
people like us and quite a few right in
my little small city okay and that's the
other side of the coin but i'll tell you
what's happening is that they're
gradually removing themselves from this
existing society
okay they are they're homeschooling
right across the country the problems i
live in has more home schooling for per
capita if you will than the rest of the
country but that's you know much that's
gone up like big time and all across the
country there are parents who are taking
their kids out of school and doing a
homeschooling program or actually
setting up alternate
outside the system schools
okay
and we have a small group as a matter of
fact you'd be interested to know and and
once again we're in the minority but but
it's a significant minority and i think
it's growing
for example tonight
my other activity on today besides
trying to catch up on my emails
which
grow by about 250 an hour
and of those like 40 are really
important
and i'm missing some of them now because
i'm trying to get through them all
because i've become very busy my wife
and myself we are sort of the on the
political side the one of the
uh leaders in canada of this movement
not just in british columbia or in my
community right
and i'm in great demand on programs like
yours okay and we'll try to try to
schedule up with tonight
it's a small restaurant in my community
in my city that wants to put on a little
dinner
with my friends for what my wife and i
are doing
hmm
wonderful actually an actual meeting in
person that's uh yes yes and they have
been opposed in their little business to
what's been going on
all through this
and have so far
not been fine we've got another business
here that has been fined and so on for
letting people in because they never had
their masks on or they weren't
vaccinated
but there's a significant in this little
city minority both of small business and
of regular citizens who are willing to
uh speak out and be part of
organizations which oppose what's
happening
so that is uh that sort of keeps me
going right the other thing that's
happened that you i'm sure be really
really interested is this
i'm vancouver island so i'm not allowed
to travel right so i can't get aboard a
plane
so i can't speak in saskatchewan
manitoba in ontario like i am in british
columbia but i can go within the margins
of my own car
right on the highways of vancouver
island and so i've done a lot of public
meetings all of which have been sold out
no no fee but you know they've
overloaded the building so that fire
regulations come into effect and all
that
but guess what's happened
and i i think many americans will be
interested in that
it's the fundamental christian
churches
that have embraced
our cause
and i've come to learn i've come to
learn and these are ones that are not
even part of the mainstream evangelicals
they're independent churches
who are taking the bible and here's what
our christianity says according to us
and they have built churches up and down
vancouver island and they all may have
different names and so on but they all
share one thing in common and i was
trying to figure out why this was and
i've spoken in of all of the public
meetings i've done the majority have
been in churches okay because they've
been willing to provide a space whereas
then nobody else in the community has
been willing to graduate but here's what
i've learned not only from the pastors
but the people who are adherents and of
course they allow other people into
anybody can come to the meeting they
don't have the members of that church
any any public can come and it's usually
about 50 50 i'd say of adherents and
others who just were interested in what
i had to say but here's why
most of these churches
are learning
in their bible studies about the early
christian church
now i wasn't so much conquered on to
this as when my wife and i back in the
early 2000s went to turkey
and we traveled to catadocia right in
the center of anatolia
okay you've been and there there are
communities that went underground
physically physically underground cities
okay
cities when i mentioned this in one of
the churches recently
the place went up
they were all familiar with it and
couldn't believe that a person who was
sort of
well you know most people know me as
well i i believe in the principles and
morality of of christianity and that we
must have a code of conduct as as a
society in order to really function you
know in a sort of a peaceful reasonable
way
but they weren't aware that i was aware
of the early church and when i spoke
about cappadocia you should see the
people's faces light up because they had
been learning about unlike
the mainstream christian religions who
have not a clue about early christianity
and how they were prosecuted because of
their point of view that was amazing
that's absolutely
fascinating and i have also seen uh it
you know it's really interesting it does
show up uh amongst christians that there
is a willingness to resist some of this
nonsense yeah i've been a little
disappointed um that jews who
have effectively uh you know taken a
multiple millennium
course in persecution have not rebelled
in greater numbers against the tyranny
that is unfolding across the west
um but nonetheless it is it is
interesting that we that there are these
communities that are not having any of
it
absolutely um and and i'm telling you i
was like right from the north in
campbell river in the northern part of
vancouver all the way down to the
capital city victoria which is on
vancouver island
vancouver is not the capital of british
columbia it's victoria
and every weekend by the way there are
thousands of people who protest at the
legislative building
in victoria organization yeah opposed to
what's going on and uh two weekends ago
they had 13 000 people
wow at the legislature in little
victoria victoria city itself is only
about a hundred thousand people yeah the
metropolitan area is about 300 000
people
but they had and are continuing to have
and i've spoken there i spoke to one of
the first rallies there and so it's
amazing to see that
right
even more amazing um i am well familiar
with victoria i've been there
multiple times you know it's a it was a
destination for people who live in the
pacific northwest on the american side
um
so i'm well aware of the place i had no
idea there were protests going on there
i mean it's you know it's a hopscotch
from here regularly and you know
thousands of people and thousands of
people
so how have they managed to keep that
secret
well because the press the game won't
carry it is not carried into times
columnist which is the main newspaper
there right i think one story out of all
of the things right uh all of the
broadcast media the tv media so you got
to reply on the alternate media in order
to get your message out and so people
and people in saskatchewan wouldn't know
and if you if you do pay attention to
the so-called alternative media then of
course there's a a a great list of
stigmas that are directed your
way so you know this is another aspect
of this that i wish people
put more thought into which is we have
no idea actually how many people believe
what and how many people can see the
tyranny um because the intimidation and
the control of our discussion has been
so thoroughly effective
no question and even all the way down to
polling now you can't trust the polls
well you never could trust them all that
much but even less so now in the sense
that people are not going to answer
either answer the phone or if they do
they're not going to give how they feel
because they're afraid that that too
will get uh somehow right okay it was
this many in this region of bc who who
said this according to the poll they
don't want any chance of getting back to
them because they're scared like you
said
yeah no it's uh
it is the most
bewildering circumstance right you can
say the most obvious things and suddenly
your life is turned upside down protests
of thousands of people can be happening
well the prime minister called us racist
misogynists
right he said
i think he said you know we had to
wonder if they're taking up some space
that they shouldn't be taking off
i recall him saying that
right yeah
leaders in the west saying things that
you know if even 10 years ago if you had
had a preview of what was going to be
said you'd think uh prime minister
saying that all hell would be the party
the party would have him out the door he
would no longer i was leader of a
political party in this country in the
province of newfoundland and labrador
and and i was a national figure for
quite some time because of my
involvement with the constitution and
other national matters okay and i know i
know the system in canada pretty well
and then i was a consultant for a number
of years right and so i've traveled in
every single jurisdiction in this
country okay every single one i've done
business in most
i've spoken most okay and i so i know
canada pretty well right and so when you
see now a political party and a country
willing to have a leader and a prime
minister who broke the law five times by
the way
that's documented five times the ethics
and conflict commissioner of canada
has produced
reports investigated the situation and
he has broken the conflict of interest
law five times in this country and
because the law has no accountability
except for a hundred dollar fine or
fifty dollar fine he still remains
leader of the political party and he
still remains prime minister of canada
and so when you have a population that's
willing to continue to support
somebody who's broken our laws whereas
if you and i broke the law tomorrow
right you know we would get significant
fines or put in jail or whatever whereas
he can walk scot-free and and and still
be the prime minister's country so
there's something rotten in the state of
denmark as our great bard would say when
that can happen
he had no question about it now you
raised the issue of his violations of
the law um i don't want to miss the
opportunity to ask you about violations
of
the constitution that you helped write
i did a quick look through your
constitution
you know it does have a lot of familiar
themes from the american constitution
and i spotted several things right away
you know even though i'm not a canadian
and i'm less familiar with what has
unfolded there was still clear that
there were several places where your
constitution guarantees rights that uh
were nowhere in evidence
what do you see as the list of uh
violations well the first one you may
not be aware i have taken the federal
government to court myself oh i didn't
know that yes and that was a that was
the other thing that
i guess
allowed me to be more of the national
figures that when i asked when i did all
these speeches you know one night i came
home and got up the next morning i said
to my wife you know i'm talking the talk
and i know what i'm talking about
because i helped create this document
and i'm on very safe ground and very
confident with what i am saying and
these violations
but one of these days somebody's going
to say to me even though i'm out there
front and i'm risking and i'm doing all
this on my own tab right and i'm going
all these places do all things
and i won't take any money i won't take
any reimbursement for what i'm doing i'm
doing it as a canadian
and it's somebody who has to give back
as well and then all the right reasons
but the other thing is somebody could
still say you know why don't you walk
the
walk
so i contacted the justice center for
constitutional freedoms which is a
organization in canada which just
depends upon contributions from the
public and they take help people go to
court to challenge the government on
constitutional grounds that's what
they're set up to do
so i contacted them and
we
decided with outside lawyers as well
that i would with four or five other
people
tate but i was the sort of the chief
claimant take the federal government to
court over their travel mandates whereas
i as a canadian sitting on vancouver
island can't get a border plane in
nanaimo british columbia and travel to
anywhere
i can't travel within my own country or
leave my country unless i'm vaccinated
and so i've challenged
that section six of the charter of
rights and freedom which says i have the
right to travel anywhere in canada or
leave canada so i'm actually
now my court case is registered
and there's now the lawyers appointed by
the federal government who argued their
side
and so we're moving through the courts
now and my hearing is likely to be in
august or september of this year and so
i might get ahead of a lot of the other
cases that are in canada challenging the
constitution because
most of the mandates in canada in canada
are provincial and have to go through
the provincial courts first then to the
supreme court of canada mine is a
federal mandate i'm challenging federal
mandate which brings me into the federal
court of canada then the supreme court
of canada so i only have two steps to go
whereas everybody else
most everybody else has three or four
steps to go so i'm actually out there
front and center actually
in the court
fighting tyranny my my government
fighting the general wielding your
constitution on behalf of your your
fellow citizens
um so let me ask you a couple things
about this um all right you're on
vancouver island which is part of
british columbia
you cannot get on a plane because you're
not vaccinated that immediately causes
you a problem on vancouver island uh you
know i mean exactly i'm on the uh
nominee you know the western part of
canada and five thousand miles away in
st john's newfoundland the province in
which i was born yeah and not only can i
go to newfoundland i can't get on the
night go to kelowna or go to vancouver
or go to victoria right um okay so
uh i know that there was a regular
ferry uh
to
i guess there was one to vancouver the
city of vancouver um can you get on that
yes okay so you can go by you can go by
boat i can go by boat but i gotta be
masculine i can go by farewell because
they're in that's inter-provincial
who's still in the same problems right
but you can't oh so you can't leave
british columbia you can go to vancouver
and go to the mainland but no on the
ferry side but i can't even get on a
plane and go to another part of british
columbia
okay got it because aviation aviation is
federal under the constitution can you
get to toronto no i can't get anywhere
in canada you can't
this is amazing
or by train
and um i'm not allowed to take the train
either um
let's suppose
that the mandates
collapse as
uh
attention turns to events in ukraine and
summer uh drives the pathogens they are
very falling now but the federal one
hasn't gone yet but let's suppose it did
what happens to your court case
stay safe because they broke the law for
all of these days and months before they
lifted it the law doesn't go away by
calendar it goes away by if you violated
it or not right good
uh and then
we're in we're in there to the end okay
and if i lose on the federal court i'm
taking the supreme court of canada i'm
not stopping until i go to the highest
court and then if the highest court
turns it down then i'll have to propose
a different kind of country than we got
now
uh well i'm going to be watching this
very carefully now i think the same
provision
uh on which the basis on which you are
suing
also guarantees
the right of canadian citizens to enter
canada
which therefore is relevant to
uh the objections that the trucker
convoy was raising um so when your court
when your case is adjudicated will their
uh
complaint effectively be adjudicated too
yes
yes that will also affect the the
truckers and everybody else because it's
the travel mandate right and if the
court rules that the federal government
violated section six of the
right of mobility in the charter rights
and freedoms then and not only that
because it's a mandate and it's a
government mandate the other mandates in
the other provinces are going to come on
a lot greater scrutiny by the judiciary
and may allow the judiciary to be a
little bit more independent than they
are right now and so or forced them to
be so my case is extremely important in
that broader context i think as a matter
of fact i'm just i write a lot
i've got my own blog i get anywhere from
10 000 to 20 000 a day going into my
blog which is
rather significant i think a personal
blog and um a lot of people depend upon
my writing and what other
things i put on my blog i'm about to
release and i'll release it publicly as
well a new essay
on the charter and where two courts
already lower courts have violated it
okay
because i want to pursue this because
as you and i both know
when people speak
and if they have a good case and you get
other people on your side you can
influence not only your governments and
your politicians although they've been
sort of absolutely
ignoring us to date because we've been
in a minority but as you keep eating
away at her right eating away at it
you may also
influence the judiciary because they are
still people they are still listening to
the news
and reading things and so i keep saying
to people in all these public meetings
we keep doing what we're doing we keep
right eating away beating away at the
at the government but also the judiciary
who become
rather conflicted in recent times as i
said to you about the female liberal
candidate now a judge in ottawa who was
the one who heard the first
part of the leader of the convoy's case
she should have recused herself the
chief justice should have said you can't
hear this case because you're conflicted
none of that happened and and
she heard the case so this is absolutely
outrageous right so if we keep eating
away at we may before it gets to the
highest courts of the land have some
impact on at least changing the view of
the judiciary so they reign in the
governments through the charter of
rights and freedoms in canada through
the bill of rights in the united states
now if we're unsuccessful which most
people think i am going to be
unsuccessful then our nation is really
really broken i take the view still that
there is a chance i put it in the hockey
game
terms because canadians understand
hockey pretty well i put i say we're in
the last part of the second period we've
got all of the first period to go
because the appeal courts haven't heard
it yet
so we've got to exhaust our existing
system to see we know it doesn't work
very well
we've got to exhaust the last part of
our system which is the appeal courts of
the judiciary
before we say we've got to do something
different
so
uh this raises a number of issues but i
must say i'm most troubled by the
implication that the uh the end of a
hockey game is the first period
is that right oh
of the period my god
game was the third period that was the
third period i see okay no i thought you
were numbering it in reverse i thought
that the you had implied that the last
that the end of the game was the first
period but that no yeah that we're at
the end almost at the end of the second
period and we've got one period to go
got it well my error um okay two things
one i want to just simply mention that
what what we see
on this side of the border
is a disturbing tendency to sideline
the
judicial and legislative branches
by a kind of bizarre
fiat in which
the executive comes up with a cockamamie
theory that says that it doesn't have to
listen to the legislature or the
judiciary and the point is that's
obviously absurd in light of our
constitution but if you believe it then
you don't ask them right and so
many of the worst provisions of uh
the anti-terrorism or supposedly
anti-terrorism
orders that emerged in the u.s
effectively grant the executive the
right to do things without review right
which wouldn't endure the court's
scrutiny but of course if you don't ask
the court then we never find that out so
i don't know if that's happening in
canada as well
not so much in canada but has started to
happen
and with uh these what they're doing is
they don't open their parliaments just
long enough to do an amendment that
nobody knew anything about and that that
wasn't um
shown in the mainstream press to give
more power to the public health officer
in their respective jurisdictions okay
and then they can go ahead and issue
more and more regulations don't have to
refer back to parliament
now i'm challenging that and i will in
my essay today and in the courts
that in the
section where the tests are to override
there's something called what all of
this must be in the context of a free
and democratic society and this is not a
free and democratic society when you can
do edicts
and repeat doing edicts based upon
something that the parliament
did six months ago or a year ago before
the circumstances changed so i'm arguing
on that case the other thing is in our
bill of right in our charter it is you
must demonstrably justify
and and my argument is they haven't
demonstrated we justified anything
because within the context of public
policy
dimensionally justifying canada means
some kind of cost benefit analysis all
governments do cost benefit analysis
it's quite common i mean it's not you
know it's not a there's nothing magic
about it and i remember when i was a
premier when i was elected that when we
would introduce new legislation we often
did cost benefit now does this really do
more harm than good or more good than
harm
and they have done none of that and
those words are right there in section
one of the charter demonstrably
justified within a democratic a free and
democratic society so we have something
but the prime minister of canada as you
remember through the trump convoy
introduced the emergency act
which was a a a a grandchild of the war
measures act
in which
they tried to uh bring in and freeze
people's bank accounts stop what was
going on in ottawa well it didn't last
very long because the investment
community both nationally and
internationally got onto them said see
around joe we're not inventing investing
in this banana republic anymore because
if you can freeze the account of this
small business when when does when does
my account get frozen because i'm i'm
involved in in canada so they took away
the emergency act but they still lift
all the other mandates which violate the
constitution including the travel
mandate that we talked about so
the the the previous as you pointed out
earlier the fact that they
uh removed the
emergency act does not change the fact
that they violated their constitutional
protection against uh unreasonable
seizure
and our cases in court challenging what
they did on the emergency not just
because it's lifted it's still there
they did wrong and they must be that
they must be brought to heal for that
wrong but
the point of it all is though that all
of the mandates around the different
provinces right many of them are still
in effect as it relates to masks are
just being removed now but they're like
the travel mandate is still there and
there are vaccine mandates still in
place where you cannot win the certain
businesses if you're not vaccinated
despite despite the fact that these
vaccines are incapable of exactly
stopping the transmission or doing
anything good and and so
the mandates are still there and
therefore have to be fought every day
and every hour of every day
so
two points one i would argue that the
absence of cost benefit analysis or risk
benefit analysis
is the hallmark of the failure of
transparency that is to say when you're
doing things for reasons other than the
ones you're stating you don't do a cost
benefit analysis because very often you
will want to do the things even though
they don't add up right for some uh some
hidden reason and the other thing i
wanted to say is
in some
sense um
we already have a problem and it's
actually a shared problem
uh
that our nations have joined together in
the five eyes alliance which effectively
uh at least i don't know what else it
does
but one of the things it does is it
allows
uh
the united states canada
and the other members to uh
basically reciprocally violate the
rights of the citizens of the five eyes
in other words canada can you know the
united states government is limited in
how much spying it's allowed to do
against americans but it can contract
with canadians to do the spying and vice
versa um and so anyway we're we're kind
of uh
we've
escaped the bounds that
uh were envisioned by the the authors of
these documents including you i think
yes i couldn't agree more i agree with
you 100 percent i would even enlarge it
the
nation state as we have understood it is
under vicious attack right now and i
believe in traveling around the world
and being involved in elective office in
canada that the the
the
the savior to mankind
and being
a democratic
organization
rests
on the shoulders of a nation state
what we have started to do in our
international agreements
like the eu started it years ago when
then was economic and then it became
political thank you for the brits to get
out of that bloody thing um and it was
only i think they had enough dna left
from the magna carta to stop doing this
and right i i was the ordinary person in
britain who stopped briefs from being
part of the united kingdom it wasn't the
wasn't the leadership it was the farmer
who suddenly realized that brussels is
going to tell him how many bushels of
wheat he could grow next year that's
what really triggered what happened in
britain
but in any case what's happening
in the international agreements now
trade agreements is that they're
infringing upon
the sovereignty of the united states of
america and the sovereignty of canada
that's where the line has to be drawn
that you do trade agreements and i'll
trade with you and you trade back with
me either by barter or whichever way you
want to do it but when you start to
interfere with the individual rights and
freedoms and the sovereignty of a nation
that the parliament of the united states
no longer has complete control over all
of its activity
that's where i draw the line and the
line has been crossed now i remember the
pacific partnership i think trump got
out of that and rightly so and rightly
so that's where every national
government should draw the line then
we'll do trade agreements because yeah
we've traded forever the greeks the
athenians were successful because they
manipul you know they managed to trade
with all of their partners in in the sea
in the mediterranean sea at the time
and so it goes back to the beginning of
man but that doesn't mean
that you can't have a trade agreement
and still have sovereignty you can have
both and that's the way it used to be
and now
the globalists
starting out of europe because they got
their european union still intact in
some way or form
even though it's not it's pretty shaky
right now
we should not go down that road
the united states should remain a
national sovereign nation canada should
and we should then cooperate where we
can without interfering with our own
sovereignty i think this is really
the best explanation for what we're
seeing is that there
is an unnamed unelected unaccountable
something that finds the sovereignty of
our nations distinctly inconvenient and
the rights of the citizens to be
an ever-present thorn in the side
and it is now it has become impatient
and it used the pandemic and i must tell
you uh
i do think that this is a very dangerous
pathogen a pathogen whose hazard is
greater than one can see in the case
fatality rate um and by virtue of the
fact that it is actually enhanced over
what nature would have delivered
but
but nonetheless it used the hazard of
that pathogen to get us to unhook
provisions of our constitutions that we
would never have unhooked under normal
circumstances and uh
you know really this couldn't be more
dangerous we will not get those rights
back if we do not defend them vigorously
and they you know
those of us who learned about this as it
unfolded are behind the eight ball right
the plan was pretty sophisticated and
highly successful before we even knew
what we were fighting about
so
uh it is time for us to wake up and
defend these documents
and what happens in canada and i'm sure
it does in the united states in general
jurisprudence here's what happens a case
comes before the court three years from
now in canada if we don't
restore our charter and our bill to
where it really belongs so if we don't
restore it and get the courts to say no
the charter comes first the charter is
in the constitution by the way we have a
thing in our constitution which says the
constitution of canada is the supreme
law of camp
it oversees all
it's above all the other laws if we
don't overturn and have the judiciary
re-establish what will happen three
years from now or four years from now
when a citizen of canada goes to court
under their individual rights and
freedoms
the judge and the judiciary have the
license to say oh back in 2022 there was
a precedent set
and it's this precedent now that we must
go by and the charter is no more
right but somehow all of the things that
made this work
right are malfunctioning
right so you know we literally had the
department of homeland security issue a
bulletin
in which
they said
that mal information was a dangerous
type of terrorism and mal information
they defined in their document as based
on fact but causing people to distrust
the government right so the idea that we
cannot discuss facts like the corruption
of our government that would cause
people to be distrustful of it is a
violation of the most basic element of
our constitution and yet
you know as far as i know the aclu has
not immediately emerged to challenge
this i i hope i'm wrong about that but
it may be that the aclu is preoccupied
uh with the kind of nonsense that it's
been uh advancing in in recent years and
hasn't noticed this egregious violation
of our most basic right
exactly exact same kind of thing is
happening in canada exactly the same
kind of thing and uh the edicts come out
of the health departments and public
health officers uh you know out of some
obscure uh emergency
declared never defined
right and that's the other thing about
it a lot of this will not pass muster in
any reasonable um definition of
emergency in canadian law but the yet
they've declared it one and therefore
because they've declared it it is one
without ever defining what the emergency
or the pandemic means
yeah you know and
i've said now in my essay which i'll
publish today for example there was a
professor at simon fraser university in
vancouver
who in april 2021 released a report
where he reviewed 80 studies from around
the world
and demonstrated through those studies
that the cure was worse than the disease
the way they had approached the cure it
was worse than the disease and he
published that he could not get any of
the mainstream media to carry it
he went on months and months without
that being carried by anybody and then
now by the way his document has been
validated over and over again very
careful
and he took all these 80 studies and he
used all the different formulas that all
of the people like to use to define all
of this okay did it properly and by the
way in that study which is absolutely
damning because
the two court cases that i use in my
essay to show that they violated okay
the constitution
these court cases came out in the late
fall
of 2021 october and november when his
report came out in april
so i'll come and and and one of the
courts was in british columbia
two and a half three miles as the bird
flies from his university
i mean you know i mean give me a break
so here you have
and in that report by the way he also
said i also said that 90 days after
the virus was declared back in march
of 2020
there were
data available which he produced
which showed
that you stay on this present course of
that kind of mitigation and you're going
to be in deep deep trouble and so he
says there was even data available so
that the governments
in august of 2020 should have changed
course as to how they were mitigating
this virus and they did not and that
data was available right so this is the
the thing that i think has been driving
many of us crazy is that uh
what i noticed
geez i can't remember the first time it
occurred to me but
what we have in the u.s and i know that
you and canada have a mirror image of it
is
um
bad public health policy that exceeds
what what incompetence could have
generated in in other words if you look
at the policy uh that we have it is
actually the inverse of the correct
thing it is not it's not even random
it's far worse than that exactly
but and then you see
a cost benefit analysis like the one
you're describing and there is no
interest in looking at it because
apparently there is some other priority
driving the policy other than the desire
to limit the spread of the virus or
protect people's health
and guess what the headline of this
report was yes that cost benefit
analysis cost benefit analysis i mean
that's that's what he headlined his
report as
it makes sense and then of course you
know the the pattern is just utterly
reliable a cost-benefit analysis
suggests there's something wrong with
what we're doing and anybody who points
out that that's what a cost-benefit
analysis said is then demonized as if
they were unpatriotic or uncaring or
motivated by greed or who knows
and guess what in the interview that
i've done in the last four or five days
okay
most of them canadian okay by very well
known
smart
um informed people uh and i've mentioned
doug professor douglas allen of simon
fraser university it's the first time
they heard of it
even to this day because of course
nobody's carried
it's a little bit like the uh the
protests in
in uh victoria that are happening
without uh
any any any awareness
yeah no it's a it's definitely a uh a
bizarre
moment and as much as we were thoroughly
warned by
orwell and others
somehow no warning is sufficient until
you see it in real time
no and i i think it speaks to history
big time
i think it speaks to history big time
you know if you don't learn from history
you're bound to repeat it kind of stuff
you know
and we've seen this over the years with
the various wars and whatever through
all of our our our
history as a home as a as a species
right there's a homo sapien or whatever
you want to call us you see it over and
over again that's why victor david
hansen by the way who you quite might be
aware of in the united states who writes
um quite prolifically uh on a lot of
things he's a classic scholar
out of california and but he he
he writes a lot in american greatness
and a couple of other websites
he just did a comparison with the the
greeks
and what's happening now and just you
know we're not learning from history
we're not learning from
not only yesterday but you know lots of
things which happen we don't know our
history we don't know
and we're not learning from it and so
we're very
as as a christian would say we're very
fallen angels don't we
well you know i i struggle there's a
certain penalty
that emerges if you
do draw
parallels to history
right you know you you can find yourself
in very hot water if you
uh draw these connections
and you know it strikes me as an
artificially high standard
right so okay we've got these vaccine
mandates it's not exactly mangala it's
not exactly tuskegee right those are not
perfect parallels but i guess my point
is at the moment that you find yourself
reaching for parallels and those are
your closest
your closest examples you are in very
dangerous water and so i don't know how
to make this point right why are we in
this section of the library looking for
analogies right right things are bad at
the point
that tuskegee becomes relevant to a
active public health program yeah um
yeah and you know like likewise the the
internment of japanese americans right
all of the relevant examples from
history are imperfect but that ought not
provide us comfort because the fact is
you know they're as close as we've got
yeah would you like to think that we
learn and that we will not
repeat
you know certain decisions which we know
were based upon data regardless of what
the nature of that data was whether it
was a virus or something else that we
won't then repeat it because we've had
knowledge of how our imperfection
in another circumstance worked out but
we don't seem to be able to do a really
good job
on advancing so technically we've
advanced ourselves but i don't know does
anybody ever come along who can
has the same impact that the socrates or
plato or aristotle has had i mean
where's our montesquiou where's our
political philosopher of the 18th
century where is ours john stewartville
i mean i don't know if there anybody
around where's our francis bacon they're
not versus cicero and so i'm not so sure
that uh on
a proper score of globally doing this
that we've advanced all that much as as
a
as a more well-rounded human being
yes uh that's true and
the other question is why do we not have
these figures and in part it may be
because to the extent that they exist
they've been so demonized and driven to
the fringe that we're not even aware of
them
good point um which is a tremendous very
sad a tremendous danger
um
all right uh is there anything else you
would like to cover before we wrap this
up no only that um and i keep arguing
and i know it's it's sort of a
i think a lot of us say but civil
disobedience is still
a very important
concept in any
sensible democracy any real democracy
that's why that thing in victoria is
very important and i keep saying that if
every legislature in canada every
saturday there were 10 000 plus people
on an ongoing basis over the next all
through the summer
that i think we could have an impact
upon public policy but without there
being civil i've put it this way
a good democracy is only one that has a
high level of civic engagement
and as the level of civic engagement
goes down so does
the level of democracy
and i think that's perhaps the best way
of putting it and you can go and look at
examples everywhere and that would be so
if
if locally in your school board
situations
you get a lot of people out voting for
their their their school board member
you'll get a better school board because
they have to be more accountable and
they know they have been more
accountable the less the civic
engagement the school board goes out and
does its own thing there's a whole bunch
of things so that then all of a sudden
there's a crisis and we've got years and
years before we can repair it so the
higher the
engagement of the individual in their
local communities as well as their
organizations nationally the better
chance we have so i say to people in
canada and the united states get
involved with your organizations that
are fighting for freedom and are
fighting to oppose these undemocratic
mandates and this may make a difference
all right well i will add one thing then
um
i don't know if it's pure coincidence
but
the groundwork for the undermining of
our
uh the western democracies was laid
before the pandemic provided the excuse
and the most fundamental element of it
was the breakdown in our ability to
agree on i think literally anything
right so i was watching in the academy
the failure of our agreement that two
plus two equals four that men cannot
magically become
uh women that pedophilia is bad right
all of these things that every
reasonable person would have agreed on
10 years ago has broken
free and we are now unmoored and i think
it is that failure which makes the civil
disobedience and the resistance that you
are talking about less likely to emerge
really these things are so
offensive to the uh the structure of our
nations and to you know to the thing
that makes the west vibrant
that their
this you know what trudeau has done
is an affront
to
citizens of any western nation and it
ought to have caused uh a universal
response and the absence of that
universal response is emblematic of the
fact that we've lost the ability to
agree on even the simplest things
i couldn't agree more i really agree
there was a poll on yesterday in canada
which showed that 48 of canadians agreed
with what trudeau did and 48
had a problem with it after all the
things he's done he's about at the
lowest level he'll ever be by the way
and the premiers almost all the dreamers
got a passing grade and their mandates
were just as bad if not worse than what
trudeau did so
that validates what you just said
unfortunately and said what a battle we
have
well uh yeah that's uh it's a terrible
note to end on but i guess i would say
that uh in this discussion i i think it
should be evident that um you know
good people who are still committed to
uh seeing the world as it is and
making it better can have a perfectly
enjoyable conversation and it has been a
real pleasure
um brian peckford where can people find
you you said you had a blog
yes they can find me
pickford number 40 number two
because i was born in
1942. so p e c k f o r d the number four
the number two dot wordpress.com
excellent uh anywhere else people should
look for you
uh
i don't think so i except because the
press won't carry it but that's the best
place to find me and um yeah i'm there
every day excellent i will put a link uh
to that in the description of this video
and uh um good luck to you sir i look i
look forward to hearing of your triumph
in the courts
[Music]